[Music]
hello you took just Lois enough friends
this is guns in here
welcome to the 41st episode of dirty
chest tricks in this episode I'm going
to show you a tricky line in bishops or
the VN opening from the white
perspective after the movie for Aoife if
you are a Vienna player then the mordor
can goes like this Knight to c3 Knight
to f6 Bishop to c4 Bishop to c5 d 3 d6
and now the aggressive move f4 and we
reach to the critical position of this
line the same thing goes for the bishops
opening clear after E for Aoife and
Bishop to c4 our line continues with
Knight to f6 d3 Bishop to c5 Knight to
c3 d6 and F phone
we pretty much reached to the same
position when I checked this position in
online database I found out that here
Knight to g4 is highest Lee played more
and in fact it's a very logical move as
after this black is indeed threatening
the move Knight to f2 navin the exchange
so what can be the wrong in this move
well yes indeed this move looks very
threatening except one fact that white
has invited black in his tricky camp and
the tricky business
start with this innocent-looking move f5
so it seems like black has created a
thread and what has completely ignored
it he had two popular choices by black
amongst them if you open and play the
move as fire then I have attached some
sample games in the PGN which will give
you a very good idea how to play against
them watch fire in this video we are
going to consider
trade on the most logical move Knight to
f2 which attacked to peace and asking
white are you busted in the opening well
of course not because here white has
this ultimate reply Quint which file so
right now what is threatening nothing
but a checkmate on f7
and accordingly black needs to react the
correct move is g6 but of course we need
to see first what happens if your
opponent plays other logical moves the
first move I want to consider is castle
which looks very natural in this
position but in fact it's a blunder move
and here the simplest refutation start
with Bishop to g5 attacking the Queen
and it doesn't matter wherever this
Queen goes let's say in this game black
continues with Quint we hate but after
the move Knight to d5 no matter however
black plays he get completely lost
position just within nine moves of the
game for example one game in database
continues with Bishop to b6 protecting
the c7 white played Knight to f3 and
black continued with the logical move c6
ejecting the night well the same result
will happen if black has taken the rook
in the corner because now White has
played this finishing blow Knight to f6
black doesn't have any good option black
has to take this Knight and here comes
the whole point
Bishop to f6 and probably black thinks
that after the move Bishop to e3 he is
covering all the vital squares but here
comes the point behind playing the move
Knight to f3 as after the move Knight to
g5 there is no way black and survive any
more so castle is completely out of the
window and saw as Queen to d7 as after
this what has this super move Bishop to
b6 taking advantage of the pain and
after the Queen to e7 and Knight to d5
black can hardly avoid the disaster in
the opening so all in all here the
obvious movies g6 attacking the Queen
and white will continue with quintet 6
so it looks bit strange because what has
given up the whole rook and it's not
clear where the compensation lies here
in majority of cases Black has tried
these three options amongst them if you
open in place King to d7 then my
recommendation is you should continue
eight knight on e4 and I have attached a
model game in the PGN which in fact give
the clear refutation of this move so
kindly check it out apart from it the
only accurate choice here is c6 and that
we are going to see in detail but the
first question one need to be us what
happens if black straight away take the
rook well here comes the simple
repetition Bishop to g5 two choices for
the black if he continued with Queen to
d7
then after Knight to d5 black is in a
big trouble as Knight to f6 is going to
appear on the board very soon and one of
my own game continues from here Queen to
e4 getting out of that folk I played
Queen to g7 attacking the room and after
rook to f8 and nightcap to c7 it's not
about winning the piece back but in fact
black king is going to be checkmated
very soon my opponent continues with
King to d7 I capture the rook on f8 and
he greedily captured my knight which in
fact turn out as a big time disaster has
after the move Queen check King to c6
Queen captures c8 King to b6 and Bishop
to d8 it's a checkmate
on the 16th move of the game
that means here only second choice left
for the black is to play f6 but after
this white will continue with F captures
g6 and this move is too strong for the
black for example one game between two
title players continues with F captures
g5
white plays the natural moon g7 and that
rook has no point to hide so black
continues with King to d7 at least
trying to support the rook but that
comes Queen to e6 check King to c6 Queen
to defy check King to d7 Queen to f7
check King to c6 Bishop to b5 check King
to b6 and finally the deciding blow BAM
ahahaha so this move provides the
disconnection between two brothers and
the cute point behind this movies
if black capture with either of the
piece let's say rook captures eh then
there comes Queen to b3 check King to c6
and Quinn to B Phi is a pretty deadly
checkmate so considering both the games
it is ill-advised for the black to
immediately capture the rook and that's
why many strong players here continues
with c6 which in fact provide great
restriction to the white pieces and now
black is all set to capture the rook in
the corner well amazingly enough even
after this move
White has the winning position and the
kick start happens with Bishop to g5 so
as you can see I have highlighted by the
arrows black has this many options but
amongst them only accurate responses
Knight to g4 raised all leads to
miserable position for the black
so let's see each bite on if your operon
plays either the move Queen to e5 or
Queen to b6 both can be made with the
same deciding blow let's say Queen to e5
and that comes boom
what a blow well if King to d7 then F
captures g6 and black is pretty much
busted so black has to accept this P
sacrifice afterwards the simple move in
the world half captures g6 check and
once again King cannot move due to the
disk of a check so black has to take
this ball and now what we'll simply gain
the rook in the corner which not only
attacks the bishop but as the black king
is isolated and open there is always a
chance to checkmate this poor guy one of
my blitz game here continues with Knight
captures h1 which allows me to prove my
point as after the sequence of moves
Queen at 7 check King to f8 Bishop to at
6 check King to e8 Queen to GA check
King to e7 Bishop to g5 check King to d7
and the prettiest checkmate on the board
quint webserver the second move I want
to consider is Queen to d7 well after
this move
what has a simple refutation starting
with Knight to e4 White's idea is
whatever black plays let's say Knight
captures h1 then here comes Knight cap
to c5 pawn captures C Phi Queen to g7
and after the move rook to f8 we are not
interested to play Bishop to at 6
because then black can survive with
Queen 26 but instead of that this lethal
reply Queen captures ePHI and by force
black has to give up the Queen
probably the most tricky is queen movies
c7 but anyways
White has the equally tricky reply push
up to be fine
so not only Luke is hanging but white is
sacrificing another piece and let's see
what happens if black accepted C
captures beef I will play Knight to d5
attacking the Queen and after the only
logical reply Queen to if I check white
Vince on the spot with before Bishop
captures before and now the easiest move
King captures night and not only
material is balanced but white has some
severe threats which in fact black
cannot parry all of them so if black
cannot capture the bishop how about
capturing the rook in the corner well
this is even a worse scenario for black
because after the continuation Knight to
defy attacking the Queen Queen to e5 and
the simple move c3 how the hell on earth
black is going to save this many threats
one game against a low-rated opponent
continues with Bishop to f2 check and of
course black cannot capture the bishop
due to Knight c7 check so my opponent
plays pawn captures B Phi but then the
disaster struck after F captures g 6f
captures g6
Queen to g7 there's a checkmate trade so
black doesn't have time to save the rook
my opponent continues wait Knight to c6
saving the mate I take the rook in the
corner he played King to d7 and no
wonder the mate is around the corner has
after Queen g7 check Knight to e7 Queen
captures a 7 King to c6 Knight to be 4
check if King to be six then Queen d6 is
a checkmate so my opponent's king has to
come up
King to see fie and now the deciding
blow quint web seven here no matter
whatever a black plays black king is
going to be checkmated in the game
he preferred Bishop to g4 but after
White's next reply Queen captures f2 my
opponent simply resigned as after Knight
to f2 and Bishop to e3 the ultimate King
Hunt is finished right there it's
amazing that none of the Queen moves are
walking in the situation so let's see
other alternatives for the black and the
first move I want to consider race Hep 6
which again can be easily dealt with F
captures g6 and after F captures g5 will
play this simple move g7 King to d7
all the same but this time around black
has an escape square on c7 so black can
argue that this variation is somewhat
better for him but still after white's
next reply that is Knight to h3 no
matter whatever black plays the game
will not last long for example if he
continued it rook to e8 then Queen 2 at
7 and we are cleaning on the next move
so that's not good for the black well
what happens if he capture of a rock in
the corner well pretty much same story
because we are going to play Knight to
g5 threatening the rook rook to e8 and
Queen - at 7 with idea of promoting a
queen with a check last but not least
what happens if black capture the night
I think this is the easiest one as after
pawn captures rook Queen captures Queen
captures h3 check King to c7 and Queen
to at 6 after the whole sequence white
emerge with an extra exchange so finally
considering all these options Knight to
g4 is only reply which if you open and
reach this position first time he will
hardly consider but anyways even after
this move White has a nagging gauge
continues with Queen to g7 so we are
attacking two spots so black responds
this force black has to capture on G Phi
we are going to capture on h8 and after
King to d7 White has this wonderful
saving resource Knight to d1 which in
fact give him the great advantage the
base sequence continues from here Knight
to e3 Knight capture c3 Queen captures
e3 and Knight to e2 we have a unique
scenario where both the Kings are stuck
in the center but due to the brave
attempt by white at the end he come up
with an extra exchange that's it guys I
hope you enjoy and learn this wonderful
tricky line in the bishops and the VN
opening remember in your tounament
practice if you reach this position then
play the move fi allow your opponent to
play Knight to have to and then give
this rude shock with Queen to h5 and get
some great attacking victories thank you
for watching this video feel free to
like subscribe and comment and I'll meet
you in my next episode very soon bye and
take care